à
ambiance festive pour les dix ans de la
pouvoir du périph
l'animal n'est pas très farouche et
pourtant dans les années soixante dix il
a bien failli disparaître la poule noire
était alors concurrencer par des poulets
à croissance plus rapide mais une
poignée d'éleveurs a réussi à sauver la
race pour le bonheur des petits et des
grands
ces poussins sont et la nuit dernière et
ils sont déjà l'objet de toutes les
attentions
la couveuse les maintient à 38 degrés
pendant plusieurs jours déjà la cia de
bons résultats en pourcentage loyer si
on avait une quarantaine deux peu près
et je pense qu'on doit rien autour de
80% de réussite donc c'est plutôt bien
c'est vrai que en phase de croissance et
en quand ils sont adultes
c'est une race très rustique et qui
résiste bien en particulier à des
pathologies qu on rencontre parfois sur
des élevages c'est la noir du berry est
tout à fait au niveau du climat de la
région et tout est bien adapté très bien
adapté actuellement en période de
reproduction
le coq ne se laisse pas approcher comme
ses compagnes gallinacés il a le plumage
noir avec quelques reflets verts elysées
sa croissance est trois fois plus lente
qu'un poulet élevé en batterie
l'année dernière 13 mille volailles ont
été commercialisés une belle victoire
pour une cause qui semblait perdue
d'avancé
c'est très encourageant parce que là
depuis on va dire le début de l'année
les restaurateurs ont vraiment joué le
jeu là et aussi bien dans le cher que
dans l'indre c'est on sent un élan déjà
par les restaurateurs donc c'est quand
même mais aussi on est ce qui me fait
plaisir de travailler avec les
restaurateurs c'est qu'on est sûr que la
volaille sera bien cuisiner et que les
gens seront appréciées vraiment sûr goût
à sa juste valeur que l'on souhaite une
poule noire du berry une blanche
alsacienne où une poule rousse la faire
se finit toujours mal dans l'assiette
pour le repas d'anniversaire la poule
noire se cuisine à la crème est ce que
c'est bon
oui on va tous finir oui moi je ne
lâcherai bien ferme comme un poulet
fermier c'est plutôt vous et puis plus
charnues certes ce n'est pas encore la
poule aux oeufs d'or
mais la poule noir du berry commence à
faire recette grâce à son goût
authentique d'autres